[Music]
ah
it's my birthday hold up i gotta change
yeah fancy shirt birthday shirt
now it's my birthday whoa
now it's a business write-off thank you
for all the birthday wishes
don't stop it the birthday over there's
no point
but we will go through these weeks of
memes
yeah can't wait for everyone to say
happy birthday yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
okay that's sick but no one plays them
august anymore
cringe come on my second attempt to get
on hawaii
and have peter bye see the pig i saw it
hell yeah a man of culture he lifts
weights
and then he builds tambourines what else
do you need
that's all you need in life baby respect
massive pp to this man
there you go well done sir attention
felix
when we start your channel name on
youtube the channel doesn't pop up oh my
god
i forgot about this
your video also has significant less
views i know then you're average i don't
want to jump to conclusion but youtube
is
shadow banning you i don't want to jump
to conclusion but you're bad
if you just let us know uh what's going
on so there's some false rumors being
spread
like i am doing it um got this new knife
by the way
it's pretty cool now it's a business
right off yeah i'm kidding
or am i anyway um yeah i don't know if
you guys noticed this
probably you didn't notice it but
because you didn't get notified
but i uh we uploaded this video right
and it got
like 9 000 views inside was on it
blessed be thy side it's like wait
what's going on like is he
glitched so we just skipped uploading
that day thinking next day it would be
fixed
and then the same thing happened people
started noticing my my video wasn't
getting any views
and it just went everywhere i think that
was a bunch of news right
what does shadow band actually mean
youtube working on fix
youtube allegedly shadow band shadow man
they creep from the shadows and then
they bang you
and then they stab you pewdiepie youtube
channel issues made fans fear a shadow
ban
valkyrie is now the fastest growing
streaming in the world have you heard of
corpse i think not
yeah they fixed it at least they said
they fixed it let me know if you can see
this video that'd be epic
i didn't think they've had shadow banned
me i assumed it was just an uh
a glitch but it begs the question how
did how does that happen
how did it how did this happen it didn't
happen to anyone else
i asked around like did this happen to
anyone else
anyone else have this not just me all
right cool that's fine
do you know that beards and rick ashley
was classmates
i have a knife now all right sorry don't
demonetize
i'm just saying it's very good for
cutting connect your bra
yeah all right garbage meme get small
peepee
i don't look around anymore nobody might
say hearing the outporn after months of
tambourines
so the nightmare begins again say strong
marzia honestly
marxist started using it right after i
recorded that video and it was the most
annoying [ __ ] ever
i'm like oh god what have i done i gotta
apologize to my neighbors
it's so loud it's so loud it does not
if you think the video was loud it does
not come across
it is so goddamn loud let me know if you
have any ideas what to do with it it's
just sitting in my room now and i
i have no clue what to do with it also
why has there not been any birthday
wishes so far
i put on the birthday suit i have a
tambourine
physical therapist suggest gamers do
five push-ups per death
to remain physically active five
push-ups that's it
weak oh i get oh okay because i have
zero deaths
or you can just you know work out
because it feels good
just work out it's not that hard you go
ooh
oh oh hell yeah big peepee that's a cool
photo
i don't know if they took it for the
subreddit but i i'm giving it a big pee
pee anyway happy birthday oh tomorrow
okay i thought i thought maybe i would
get like a
birthday wish but yeah happy birthday
[Music]
martha
i'll hurt the tamron remember kazoo kid
this is him now feel old yet
but you feel old but you feel nine years
old
nobody might say your creations
here comes my chat check what's that
oh [ __ ] it's a haiku one hell yeah
it's one of my favorite anime i saw it
seen in a while
so what so you admit
i say that
[Applause]
damn holy [ __ ]
all right i don't need birthday wishes
that was 10 out of 10. well done
ernest t very nice huge peepee my
favorite comment on any pewdiepie video
you need to stop screaming my name in
the beginning of the video i get so damn
excited yeah
i've seen this i like that even la why
lava thank you for watching lawai that's
actually what we named the show for we
didn't steal it from anyone
appeared in among us voice chat pewds
telling
knock knock jokes after dying yeah
because the game has to be spun
somehow it's just so satisfying i'm
sorry i don't mean to be threatened
people all the time but
all i'm saying if a watermelon
approaches me in a dark alleyway
i'm not saying anything actually but
what i am saying is
how can i look as threatening as
possible by holding this i feel like the
shirt makes at least
at least frightening
that was my threatening face that's
terrible
this is a problem being a swede we're
the least threatening people of all time
the camera angle in anime when a
character is about to go absolutely
insane there it is i as soon as i saw
that still image i knew there was going
to be memes of it thank you so much
i love it so much i'm so glad i keep
seeing this image
it's not even of me in kindness there's
evil in evil there's kindness of course
we have the balance
then there's pure good and then there's
this [ __ ]
yeah i'm not gonna threaten anyone but
if i see a sheep
i will build a candle freaking machine
that's all
calm down youtube don't shadowband me
i'm kidding
okay
there you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
now we need corpse on that deepening
voice
oh god that's uncomfortable oh hell yeah
well done that's sick maybe now i'll
have to play among us again eh
huh if i'm gonna get in trouble for a
bunch of [ __ ] that i haven't said i
might as well take credit for
it i haven't said it as well there you
go that's the real quote thank you
that actually looks in jail well done
big baby i respect it
all right we got a lot of sick
animations thank you guys
hell yeah oh yeah boy
say big peepee well done all those
things played
al porn 19 year old okay
marzia the neighbors yeah uh i did get
they did ask me about it but they were
okay with it i have good neighbors
luckily
thank you don't report me to the alcorn
police please all right
no birthday wishes as well it's whatever
i don't really care i swear to [ __ ]
on
every goddamn time it's mr b's birthday
subreddit go
[Music]
it's my cf birthday oh my god i must sim
all these random youtubers i barely even
heard of
oh my god it's their birthday what are
we doing deploy the birthday
it's fine it's fine i'm not mad
yeah don't give her ideas please no more
ideas for myself don't stop sending
these all right
our house already looked like a living
nightmare
[Music]
okay nice thank you
thank you that gets a peepee of honor
because finally someone realized here
you go what do you get
i don't know i don't want to give away
money uh my meme
yeah baby that's what i've been waiting
for that's what it's all about
that's good [ __ ] sweden does something
pewdiepie swedish science
is the world's finest is this jojo is
that what i think it is if it's jojo
and i don't approve of the jojo anymore
tomorrow
thank you peters for keeping me company
while i'm at the hospital for having a
seizure god damn
i hope you're doing well i'm i'm always
glad my videos can entertain you guys
but if you're not entertained i am not
the neighbor's kid quesadillas
obviously come on tambourine and all
porn companies after inventing pewdiepie
it's interesting to think that me and
ksi probably have a significant impact
on the al porn what is it called like
business
feels good man yes among us
please we need a tambourine in the game
everyone is asking for it literally
everyone hey
among us look at fall gas right it was
the hutch
everyone was playing with it but they
didn't add a pewdiepie skin
game went back down faster than you
could say
ball guys huh as long as you don't want
that to happen you want a pewdiepie skin
trust me on this one
okay okay happy birthday marks yeah
check what's that no no
pewdiepie when he gets a really good fan
art i want to upload because i'm not
like
okay someone just gets really good
feather that's actually insane you get
turned in what oh powerful award for
that what is that
case that gives out way money to fan art
okay start with the nose he's got a
little bit of that handsome squidward
vibe to him i'll give him that
am i the only one to see it i'm feeling
this oh yeah
i'm sorry ksi please give me money he's
gotta look good otherwise he's not gonna
give me money
okay cool the chain is becoming a little
bit like uh
we have a little bit of uh abdul vibes
to this i like that maybe we'll do like
a crossover
dude he could totally he's got the
bandana he's got the chain
if kesai doesn't dress up as abdul on
halloween i'll be disappointed that's
all i'm gonna say
huge shoulders huge breastsicles
tiny nipples the pinnacle of man will do
the jojo
signs because they look like a jj so it
makes perfect sense all right let's save
this
spend a lot of hours on this hope
it's worth a ward
and then and then you gotta have some
self-deprecating like
or just like pitying a pity bait like uh
i just want him to see it really
would make my life there we go
boom all right upload this please for
the love god upload this
wait i can't upload my own what is this
[ __ ]
come on kiss i please
i got i spent all that money on the tear
on the outboard
where's the dick richard yeah it you can
explain it that doesn't mean it makes
sense
dumb asses
oh my god why did i not see this
hell yeah and maya nugget too
that's amazing huge peepee pigeon lover
hell yeah that's sick
what the [ __ ] and they used to imagine
so a lot of people are confused that me
and uh me and maya and edgar had the
birthday on the same day i can prove it
every time we uh i i register my dogs
i always put the the birthday as my
birthday so we
we share the birthday it's legally it's
entirely legally possible okay
where's my it's entirely legally
possible okay
we have the same birthdays
honestly the truth is it's in reverse
i will delete my youtube account if i
get close to pewdiepie subscriber
account
now i'll delete my first mr beast you
need to go on you're the chosen one
stop with this photo big peepee though
yes i mean no please for the love of god
stop don't give her inspiration
oh thank you there it is a jojo
oh look at that you're so cute you know
what you get the
tarnian award a metaphys
a spiritual version turn in
yeah that's better isn't it yeah oh
you get a tambourine hit yeah that's
better
yeah you won that yeah hey pierce after
you uploaded your first workout video it
really inspired me
hell yeah let's get it good progress man
keep it up
it's cool that i inspired you guys start
lifting immediately
immediately
[Music]
how can you be scared of this it's so
cute
it's lit it's the least threatening i
need to get rid of this this is going to
cause problems
i'll put it away in arm's length i made
a pewdiepie skin without legs
well done what can i say but just good
job you did it
when pewte sees your post but scythe
cuts it out of the way
why is that such a good meme i'm glad
grease ball is
popping up man
this one this one i will let slide that
that's a good one
oh happy birthday martial oh marcia
the pasta
i just finished season two i know
everyone was crazy about me watching
avatar and it was so annoying
and it's so childish the first episodes
but it gets
actually good it gets really good so you
were right
and i'm willing to admit i was wrong
guys i made a mistake all right i
pre-judged avatar and it was actually
great
oh my god never seen photo of pewdiepie
and his father will show
that's freaky man he's got the pewdiepie
gloves on even what the [ __ ]
all reality football pewdiepie family
[Music]
side editing videos and seeing felix's
donate to brad for the second
one all right this time is online i will
i will i'm just
okay
[Music]
he got shadow back our biggest creator
no i'm not
youtube trying to explain my pizza's
shadow pen
yeah yeah it was weird it was weird
what in the world
hey come on
nice all right oh yeah
oh going up hey
[Music]
nice
it's so good jack's films did the melody
and the whole song by the way
i stole it off him as a meme just want
to be clear like that's his song
but that's cool to hear it though sounds
great oh i couldn't turn 19 without a
pewdiepie
cake that's so sweet happy 19.
that's epic are we moving to 29 soon
because i'm 31 now
the fiercest looking snail ever oh my
god
that must be a 19 year old snail right
there
holy [ __ ] dude the oldest condom was
invented in sweden
you are welcome you are
welcome what can i say except you're
welcome yeah how big is that that's a
tiny pt what the
dude from sheepskin
someone saw a sheep and was like i could
put that on my peepee
hell yeah go sweden yeah
oh there it is are we blind deploy the
birthday wishes
thank you guys so much i had a great
birthday it was really really fun
i'm just really thankful that such a
cool fan base and thanks for uh
supporting me throughout the years i
like it i like support
so you know smash like subscribe and all
that jeep
jabber and i see you guys tomorrow hey
dog
bro fish yeah
[Music]
one